[Musique]
la rosa se passe
on va tous bords y avait dit cette année
soit une promenade de santé
j'avais dit que ce serait presque comme
une promenade de santé
ce genre d'épreuve nous rassembler super
de retrouver
une aventures de thor le dieu guerrier
fichtre
allons-y en avant toute
les enfants sortaient le pop corn et
laissez moi vous conter l'histoire du
viking de l'espace tort aux dîmes sonne
ce n'était pas un homme ordinaire
c'était un dieu
après avoir sauvé la terre pour la 500e
voiture s'est embarqué dans un nouveau
voyage
il s'est remis en forme il a perdu son
ventre est retrouvé son corps de dieu
et après tout ça mieux il est finalement
redevenu
seul et unique tome
où j'ai parlé trop vite
[Musique]
petite amie
ça fait combien de temps 3,4 en huit ans
7 mois et 6 jours plus ou moins
[Applaudissements]
je perçois estimant
et seuls 7 qui importe aux yeux des
dieux
cette eux-mêmes
voici tongon serment
tous les dieux faut mourir
j'allais dire qu'est ce que tu as fait
là bas m'a beaucoup impressionné
c'était mon premier méchant
on n'oublie jamais sa première fois
non tu ne ressemble pas aux autres dieux
que j'ai tué
une chose pour laquelle se battre
[Musique]
voyons voir qui tu es que ton
déguisement disparaissent d'une
pichenette
au en fait trop comme d'habitude
on lui donne pas un coup de main or rien
de presse des raisins